welcome back to the special edition of
Hannity the world is on fire and so is
Joe Biden's birthday cake with 81
candles apparently as it turns out 81
candles creates quite a flame almost
nothing is going right for Joe Biden or
the country that he serves tonight
according to the Pentagon US soldiers
have been attacked at least 66 times in
the last few weeks this includes a major
strike against US forces at an Airbase
in Iraq take a look at this and since I
know you'll ask US forces have been
attacked approximately 66 times since
October 17th 32 separate times in Iraq
and 34 separate times in Syria us
Personnel have sustained approximately
62 injuries but this does not include
any injuries from last night's attack as
they are still being evaluated in
response the US has launched a few
different air strikes in the region
including one against an Iranian
revolutionary guard facility in Iraq but
so far these counter measures have to
deter uh attacks the world is at War
American soldiers are broader at risk
the economy is a disaster and the
81-year-old president is barely able to
form a coherent thought Biden is now in
down almost every Pole to every possible
Republican hopeful including Donald
Trump but Joe doesn't seem to have a
care in the world he's headed to
Nantucket for a luxurious and relaxing
Thanksgiving with his family and friends
joining us now with the reaction former
Arkansas Governor Mike Huckabee the host
of out kicks Tommy lren is fear Fearless
Tommy larren and Fox News contributor
Joe kcha you know I'm going to start uh
with you Mike Huckabee you know we've
had uh now they say 66 times since
October 17th that we've been attacked uh
by the proxies in Iran uh from Iran and
yet we are barely fighting back why do
you think that is when so many of our
soldiers have been injured with injuries
that are very serious TBI traumatic
brain injuries which are can be
lifelong well John you got to remember
this is an Administration that has given
a lot of cash Awards to the Iranians uh
We've blessed them not just with the $6
billion doar of unfrozen money but we've
turned their oil spigots back on that's
80 billion bucks they've been able to
get from that so we're obviously not
that worried about what they do we're
making it possible for them to gain
nuclear capacity and I just believe with
all my heart that if Donald Trump were
still president and I hope he is again I
don't think we'll have this kind of
situation because the Iranians won't
take these chances instead Joe sitting
there with his birthday cake that
thing's flaming up so much my gosh I
think it increased global temperatures
by
2° nationally it looks like a forest
fire I'm expecting Smoky bear to rush in
there and put it out and say only you
can prevent fires like this Joe yeah you
know I got to tell you Tommy I think
that that birthday cake with 81 candles
on it I mean as as opposed to getting
eight and one two candles I think it's a
metaphor uh for America that we're in
flames right now whether it's the
economy crime the Border what's going on
in the Middle East what say
you yeah it really looks like a dumpster
fire and that is the perfect symbol for
Joe Biden's presidency but you know it's
one thing to be off with your family for
Thanksgiving most presidents do that
there's nothing wrong with that the
problem is that according to a lot of
research by the RNC he spent about 40%
of his presidency on vacation now White
House sources will say Hey listen Joe is
working while he's on vacation well he's
not even working when he's in the Oval
Office I don't uh really buy the fact
that the man that can't figure out which
is the exit or when to leave or when to
enter he can't call on reporters without
a cheat sheet I highly doubt he's
working while he's on vacation on the
beach or in Nantucket or wherever he
wants to go this President is entirely
asleep at the wheel which means somebody
is running this country into the ground
and I didn't vote for Joe Biden judge
but I certainly didn't vote for whoever
is running our government right now and
me and millions of other Americans would
sure like to know who that person is you
know um Joe kcha the amazing part of all
this is the Democrat Party they talk
about oh for choice and freedom and all
this stuff 71% of the Democrats think
Joe's too old to do the job and yet
they're insisting that he be the guy to
run they're you know he's not engaging
in any kind of debates uh it's Joe Biden
when America clearly I mean we we're
tired of The Stumbling and the bumbling
what say you I say judge if there was a
plan B which I think was supposed to be
kamla Harris and now she's all the way
back to plan Z if there was somebody
viable to put forward then that would be
one thing but they just don't seem to
have too many options but regarding this
Nantucket vacation here for six days one
would think that somebody who is
nicknamed Scranton Joe would go back to
his hometown in Pennsylvania but every
Thanksgiving Mr Biden always seems to
have friends with homes so big that they
have their very own ZIP code that you
can probably see from outer space and
this just shows you judge and this is a
problem for the Democratic brand in
general they are no longer the party for
the working man or woman but they're the
party for Elites for hedge fund
billionaires like the home that Mr Biden
is staying in the richest 1% of the
richest 1% I mean we're certainly a long
way from Wall Street Occupy Wall Street
that's for sure and as usual Biden looks
profoundly toned deaf to be staying at a
Nantucket estate valued of $34 million
all while so many families will be
struggling to put food on the table this
Thanksgiving and in fact the average
cost of a Thanksgiving meal this year is
the second highest ever on record it's
also 25% higher than it was in 2019 When
Donald Trump was in office and this is
why there's several reasons why uh
Donald Trump and poll after poll as you
just showed beating Joe Biden not only
nationally but in those important swing
States Georgia Arizona Michigan
Pennsylvania Wisconsin Nevada and this
is why many Democrats like David Axelrod
are publicly saying get out Joe you
simply cannot win the question is who do
you put in Mar R mariana rivera is not
waiting in the bullpen that's certainly
for sure all right Mike hucke I'll go
back to you you know but Joe Biden will
tell you kierre actually will tell you
that bomic is great but I can't help but
agree with Joe and what you said earlier
if Donald Trump were the president right
now we wouldn't be in this
mess well I don't think we would uh I
find it interesting that Karen John
Pierre would say such things about how
great bomic is I wonder if there's one
American family that will gather around
the table and when they say their prayer
of Thanksgiving we'll say thank you God
for bonics thank you you that our
groceries and gasoline cost more thank
you we can't afford a house or a car yes
God thank you for bionomics it makes us
all feel what most of the rest of the
world has to feel living in poverty we
used to live in real Prosperity but no
longer thanks to Biden nomics yeah and
you know Tommy I mean in in the end what
you've got is a is a party that is
pushing Joe on us you know Donald Trump
and and there are several in the who
were in the presidential primary but
Donald Trump it seems the the more that
time goes on it's clear to everyone that
he's the guy that we've got to have in
there to fight the fight for America
with all of these attacks on Air Force
on our on our um uh military guys in
Iraq and Syria I mean they're not afraid
to hit
us if only it were that easy as us
wanting Donald Trump to be in office and
if only the polls gave us the full
picture you know judge I don't want to
be the Grinch this early before
Christmas but I will say this the reason
the Democrats are they're scrambling but
they're not in full panic mode and
that's because they know that they have
the electioneering ground game down
they've got early voting they got Mass
mail and ballots they are ready to go so
they can hide Joe in the basement that's
how confident they are so I'd love to
sit here and be cocky but we really
can't afford to do that yeah last time
it was the basement campaign this time
they call it the bubble campaign all
right Mike Huckaby Tommy lar and Joe kin
thanks so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else